today
we're in the heart of the republic we
were in the heart of the republic last
time looking at epic fourth of the soul
we talked about the parts of your soul
or your personality and which ones
predominate and how they should be
arranged
now we're actually looking at a story
and that story has some some backstory
to it
and a lot of that is actually in
other dialogues by plato
or in other parts of the public that
we're not reading
so i'm actually going to give you
an outline plato's theory of the forms i
created a handout for you that you can
you know
use
it may help you with this sort of thing
when they're looking at the the real
things in the out in the outside world
in the allegory of the cave
plato is talking about the forms
and so we'll talk a little bit about
what those are but first we ought to
think about this allegory
you guys know that word right allegory
another word that's similar to it is
parable
what's an allegory or a parable
if you had to put it into a larger class
kind of what yeah
it's a story right and
you'll see two words often use story or
another
fancier word that we often use in
academics
narrative right all the narrative is is
a story
and
um
in a way it's more fun than
the dialogues you've been reading so far
which are mainly just guys sitting
around arguing with each other right and
talk on book not even doing much
argument just just um saying here is
here's how it is here's how it is oh yes
socrates that sounds good you know
um
here socrates is actually telling a
story and he will actually do this plato
will have him do this in a lot of the
dialogues so if you go on and you read
more platonic dialogues
he'll every once in a while stop and
tell an interesting story he does some
more in the republic towards the end
some of them get pretty wild and crazy
and there's a lot of you know
speculation why does he tell stories
instead of just doing philosophy
well you know what is it that people
like about stories
what is it that you like about stories
you can relate it to real life yeah you
can relate it not just to real life but
to
your life right you can you can
sometimes some stories you like because
you can see yourself in the story
right
and some stories you actually don't like
because you have a hard time relating to
the story
that may change as you get older
i remember some stories that i got
nothing out of when i was your age
when i was you know reading them again
in my 30s i was like wow this is amazing
stuff
well you know sometimes you have to have
things happen in your life or you know
think about certain things in order for
it to
click and refer to gel
this is a story about
something kind of generic
and in that way it's like a parable
um an allegory is a story that's
actually telling another story right so
it was a parable
where you guys run across parables
i'm going to bet you run into
the bible the bible is full of parables
somebody will you know raise some issues
let me tell you a story
sower went out to sew and he threw seed
over here and over here and over here
and over here and this is how it turned
out and is that really a story just
about a sewer going out just to you know
throw seeds around you might actually
say what you know what's wrong with this
guy he's throwing seeds all over the
place he's getting it on the stony
ground he's not a very good farmer at
all it's not about that sort of thing is
it
it's about something else and we don't
have to go into that because that's a
theological question
but with any sort of story along these
lines when somebody's telling it they've
got some they've got some object in mind
what's this story basically about
you know it's about a guy in a cave but
go go beyond that what is the story
fundamentally about
it's about boy meets girl
boy
does the wrong thing boy loses girl boy
wins girl back that's a story
very common one
that's not this story isn't it
is this a
coming-of-age story little johnny you
know goes off with his three friends
into the woods and they find a dead body
and some mean kids trying to steal it
from them and you know and then he got
stand by me
it's not that kind of story either right
you notice that we have different types
of stories
what is this story about
that's kind of a more elevated
story
socrates actually does tell you at one
point
which is why it's an allegory not just a
parable
i'll give you hint it has to do with
what we're doing here
in this class which is called
the philosophy exactly
this is you know moving away from the
ordinary world the realm of appearances
the realm of opinion where people don't
actually know what they're talking about
to the realm of
knowledge or wisdom and you get there
through
through philosophy
and plato had some very definite ideas
about what you ought to be doing when
you're doing philosophy
he wouldn't have you guys actually doing
this
he wouldn't have you sitting in desks
and rows
and
you know listening to lectures and
occasionally engaging in discussion he'd
have you first of all like in learning
mathematics
and he talks about that a little bit in
this book
what's what's good about mathematics
other than you can balance your
checkbook which which is good
if you can't balance your checkbook
you're you're in definite trouble
mathematics is different than other
types of studies
show me number one
you can't do it
how many of you have one thing
everyone should be raising their hand
now you've got one thing in the air all
right
is that one is that number one
itself no
no
but you can add number one
to number four
without even you know counting on your
fingers or or you know using a
calculator or anything like that without
using you can do it in your head right
i hope so one plus four is
all right we're not using
a very complex mathematics here
what you did just now is you manipulated
concepts in your mind
that have
no necessary connection to physical
things
you abstracted away from matter
you didn't realize you were doing that
but that's that's what you're doing
numbers are something like what plato
calls the forms
plato actually thinks this is skipping
ahead a little bit that there's
literally two worlds there is the world
that we're seeing right here
the world where we're all material
things
and where when we see
anything
and we know what it is it's never
perfect
think about circles for example
what's wrong with this circle
go ahead
it's not a good circle why why
yeah well it's not perfectly round
exactly and and now i'm sloppy so and
you know that from my writing i will
never draw a round circle in my life
even if you give me a protractor you
know i don't know if you guys use those
back in geometry class you still use
those
surprised
we used to poke each other with them you
know
even with that i couldn't get it to be
perfectly perfectly round well you know
because in this material world
things like circles are not perfect
and it works that way with other things
if i say
that he is a just man
and she is a just woman
i'm not actually saying
in this world
that they are perfectly just as a matter
of fact even if they're really really
good people
there might be certain angles you could
look at them from and say
he's not just in this respect just like
a circle is you know you recognize this
as a circle you didn't think it was a
square right
but you could also recognize it's not a
very good circle
that's the way it works with plato's
forms they are the ideas and the
material things are actually copies
now if you pursue this line of thinking
too far you wind up in all sorts of
paradoxes and we're not going to go that
far with it i just want you to know that
plato thought that there were these
things called forms and that to know
the individual thing
was to actually know the form that it
participates in
and that takes a lot of doing
you know if the forms are not here right
in front of you material
how do you get to know them
you have to abstract your mind away from
the purely material things
plato in another dialogue talks about
your body as being the prison of your
soul
that your soul actually
got to see
real things
the most real things the forms in a
former life
and now it's just sort of dimly
recollecting them when it sees them in
immaterial things
so for example when i see
man
i think of myself as a man
or let's say a human being because it
would make it very generic
um i'm actually
recalling the ideal form
of man that we participate in we're
imperfect copies of it
insofar as i am who i am
greg sadler age you know 41
uh six foot three
probably somewhere around 270 pounds or
260 pounds or something
and so far as i have all those
characteristics
i'm just me i'm not the ideal form of
man but i participate
in that ideal form and that's what makes
me human same thing with him
same with her and you know this is kind
of interesting because think about all
the differences that we have
the ideal form of human being
would it have gender
if it did could women participate in it
if it was male or if could men
participate in it if it was female
so it doesn't have gender
would it have skin color
could it
no
it wouldn't be of any determinant height
or weight
or age
but it would contain the essence of what
makes us human
that's the way plato thought about these
things so that's background to this this
story
ultimately what the person is doing
getting out of that cave is getting to
see the real
things so let you know let's think about
this this story how does it actually
work
you've got
a guy in a cave
we don't know how he got there what do
we know about it
what do you remember from the story
yeah
yeah he's stuck staring straight ahead
yeah there's there's shadows right
where the shadows coming from
they're from behind him right
so there's something projecting it plato
says that there's a fire behind him and
there's people walking around
you know like carrying things and they
cast shadows on the wall and
you know you might ask yourself who are
those people he doesn't actually go into
any details does he what he's more
interested in are the prisoners because
this guy isn't just chained by himself
he's chained with a whole bunch of other
people
and they can't look around they can't
look behind them and see what's going on
all they can see are the things going on
in front of them so this requires a
pretty big leap of imagination on your
part you know because you might ask
questions like
how do they eat
when they want to go to sleep
how come they can't turn around
could you really chain somebody that way
you know you can ask all those sorts of
questions
but the allegory isn't going to answer
them for you the allegory is trying to
push you towards something else
so
this guy's life changes how does it
change
screaming
exactly
yeah he thinks that well he's never seen
the sun to begin with and all of you can
relate to this you've all been in a dark
room at one time and then you go out in
blazing sunlight
and it hurts doesn't it
um if you're
which you know i'm sure it's not never
happened to any of you because you're
all underage if you're hungover it makes
it even worse
you know that that sun just cuts through
your brain and you know you almost wish
it could go away
you can't see anything
the light is actually too bright
light is what we need to see right but
if the light is too much for your eyes
you can't see
just like when you're walking around at
night you've actually got your night
vision and you have a bright light shine
in your face you can't see after that
can you
so he doesn't know what's going on all
he knows is he's dragged out of this
place and up towards the surface
and then they talk about somebody saying
tell me what that is tell me what that
is tell me he can't do anything can he
he doesn't know what anything is all
he's seen are shadows
so he's really at a loss
now
if you've ever been doing philosophy and
you find yourself with this totally
confused feeling
you're like that prisoner in the cave
when he first gets dragged up he doesn't
know what to do he doesn't know what's
happening to him he doesn't know whether
it's going to kill him or not
all he knows is this is something
totally alien to my experience and i
don't really like it
but they make them stay there
what do they do next
what do they do with this guy
all of you read it right
what do you remember about this
do they feed them and clothe them and
send him on his way
the hot meal
good luck buddy
they don't do that right
what do they do
they teach them a bit don't they
how do they do that
do they throw them into the deep end of
the pool
let's say it was swimming right how did
all of you learn microsoft did you have
swimming lessons
or did your parents throw you in the
water and say swim
some people do that
right
you can do that with a lot of animals
and they will sort of automatically do
it
if they don't then
i guess you have to go in and save them
is that what they do with this poor guy
what do they do i mean he can't look at
a lot of things can he
he certainly can't look at the sun
can you look at regular things
at first
like trees or human beings or
candy bars
in our world automobiles
buildings
he can't right so what is how does he do
that yeah he like starts by looking at
like the shadows on the ground and then
reflections of an actual thing very good
he starts with what he knows
reflections on the ground or not shadows
on the ground and those are like the
shadows that he saw in the cave right he
can relate to those and then he sees
reflections in pools and those are kind
of like shadows aren't they except
reflections are a lot better
think about when you you know you
do whatever you do in front of the
mirror in the morning like get dressed
or you know maybe some of you shave or
put on makeup or things like that you're
awfully glad that it's not just one
blank shadow
right you can actually see things it
gets more distinct it's more what we
call intelligible
you can actually tell what things are
and then when you go from that to real
things
that's wonderful
now he's really starting to enjoy
himself
he's really starting to to get at things
and he's going now notice what he's
doing this is going from
copies
to
realities
and before all he knew were the copies
and copies are okay right copies aren't
copies of something they're not nothing
but they're just copies
let's think about that for a minute how
many of you
would prefer to
with a pick your favorite band
how many of you would prefer to just
stay home and listen to the cd
over and over again
or would actually like to go and hear
the band live
let's say money was no object
because i know concerts are expensive
these days they used to be cheap when i
was young
but you know everything they kind of
jack you guys around
everything's more expensive for you guys
education gas milk loans
how many of you would prefer to listen
to the cd by by showing hands
how many of you would prefer to go see
the band
why
i mean isn't the cd just as good as the
band
isn't it even just like their best
tracks
yeah there's like a i guess there's an
experience about going to a concert that
you can't get just by seeing listening
to the music let's say
we can try to replicate your concert
experience
you can pack a whole bunch of people in
your room
and they you know turn off the
sprinklers so they can all light their
lighters
and
again you know somebody's selling
t-shirts over here and somebody's
selling beer and soda over here and a
lot of jostling going on wouldn't that
be
just as good no
why not
his room would probably get destroyed
there could be bad consequences
um
you noticed that it wouldn't it wouldn't
work and you may not be able to
articulate exactly
why it wouldn't suffice why it wouldn't
be as satisfying to you but it wouldn't
be as satisfying to you
how many of you would like to look at a
picture of a very tasty meal
as opposed to
actually eating that meal
or how many of you would prefer to have
um i mean have any of you you guys
haven't been to the culinary yet right
right up the road
make sure to take a trip up there and
and go to the restaurants and um
check it out the food is amazing you
know
and then compare that say to mcdonald's
mcdonald's is good for certain things i
mean i kind of like
quarter pounders with extra onions on
them and you know when i have my kids
then i tend to eat more mcdonald's
because my kids like mcdonald's
but does mcdonald's measure up it's not
even like a
copy of
a really good hamburger that you would
get somewhere else
and you know that right you can relate
to that
what are some other examples where
you in your experience the copy is just
not as good
and you can feel it
you don't have to like reason about it
you can feel that the copy's not as good
how many of you have boyfriends or
girlfriends
not that many of you
wow
how many of you had boyfriends or
girlfriends
almost everybody okay good so
think about the difference between
actually seeing them and talking on the
phone
which is more satisfying
seeing them right and well if you don't
unless you don't like them
right
but for most cases
the copy the thing that comes away from
them
the thing that's derivative is just not
as good it's not as satisfying it's not
as pleasing
why because it's not as real
if you were to find out
that right now you're not actually
living in the real world
think about these science fiction movies
we're going to talk more about these
over the course of the semester
think about these science fiction movies
where somebody figures out that this
isn't the real world
how do they take it
how do they do with that
what are the what are their reactions
usually
let's start with what are some movies
like that that you can pick up
because maybe there hasn't been one
recently
think about the movies you've seen
it turns out somebody's in a
fake world
what have you seen like that
what's that
yeah that's a recent one
say say it louder
inception yeah um that one has to do
with
dreams right yeah yeah
so that's one kind of unreal world um
there's been another one recently like
that
you've all seen the matrix right the
matrix movies the matrix movies are like
that except it's a computer generated
thing and they're using human beings as
batteries to charge up the machines
have any of you seen dark city
it's kind of a cool movie or the 13th
floor
same kind of same kind of deal
there's another movie that came out
about the same time called the game that
he had
michael douglas in it
and he realizes that you know the thing
that he's experiencing is fake there's a
lot of ways you can do that sort of
movie how do the the heroes typically
react
they're shocked they're shocked abused
okay those are initial reactions you're
right
um
and then how do they feel
they say oh it's so wonderful that
somebody created a fake world for me
that's great
what's that betrayed
they feel betrayed and they they often
get kind of angry and and mean
and all that there's actually a great
scene in the matrix
probably the best scene in the matrix
where
um
it's not keanu reeves it's uh
what is his name um i'm forgetting the
name of the actor he's the one who sells
them out
do you remember the scene where he's
actually deliberating with uh
what do they call those guys the agents
right the agents about how the salmani
says
and he's cutting into like a steak and
he says i know this isn't a real steak
but i i'm you know i'm tired of living
in a
tough crappy
world where you know we're eating
oatmeal basically all the time i'd
rather eat an imaginary steak
he's
sort of fallen back to the realm of
copies because that can be more pleasant
later on in the semester when we look at
rene descartes descartes is going to
talk about this precise issue about
knowing that you're in the real world
this guy is is experiencing that with
the cape
he's coming out of
a realm of copies a realm of
essentially illusions
that people think are real
and he is experiencing real things what
happens um once he's actually got his
head around all this
now he's got a choice doesn't he and
what what
what's his dilemma he feels kind of bad
for the people downstairs
what is it you decide to do
perhaps
ill advisably
what does he do
just stay up there looking at trees and
people and
all that
exactly he comes down into the cave and
he says
hey the stuff that you're looking at
it's not really real let me tell you
about what happened to me
now
how well has he received
not well at all i see you shaking your
head
um
some of them say we're gonna kill you
why do they do that well you know think
about it from their perspective he comes
down there and he's and he's stumbling
around he can't figure out where he is
because he's been in the bright light
the real light for so long that when he
goes back into the darkness he can't
really see he can't make things out he's
not as fast to pick out what those
shadows are even though
he has seen what the realities are
that the shadows are just copies of he
in some way knows the shadows better
than they do because he actually knows
what they're supposed to be
he knows what they're supposed to
represent
but he can't express himself very well
and they think this guy is just full of
it
we're going to go upstairs
look at him
he can't even walk around down here
he doesn't know what that shadow is over
there
and they reject what he what he has to
say
and they you know they threatened to
kill anybody else who would do that sort
of thing
now um
this is an allegory for philosophy
philosophy may not get you killed
usually it doesn't
they can in some places still today
if you know if you go against the
reigning orthodoxy if you go against
what they say the shadows have to be
they can get you killed in some places
luckily this isn't one of them
he got socrates killed right
because he refused to stop doing
philosophy we looked at all those texts
and what socrates was doing
remember how socrates is always saying
don't i don't know anything i'm just you
know i'm just this guy real humble and
you know questioning people turns out
that wasn't completely true it wasn't
if this is really the case
if socrates has been outside of the cave
socrates does know some things
and socrates is trying to lead people
outside of the cave himself
and how does he do it well that's that's
what's discussed in the rest of the book
um especially in book
seven the second part
all this talk about dialectic and
studying mathematics all of that is
supposed to lead you
to the forms
so
you know again just to recap think of it
like this there's
for any given
things that we call realities
there's a form
there's one single form
and there are many material
things
and this is the original
and these
are all just
copies
and so you know if you actually have
this point of view
this is a metaphysical point of view
this is about what reality really is
then um you're going to want to get in
touch with those forms
you're going to want to spend your time
contemplating those and you're really
not going to want to spend too much time
messing around with with bodily things
you know you'll eat so that you can
contemplate the forms you'll
make sure to you know
attend to how you look and you know
maintain basic hygiene so that you can
live so you can attend to the forums and
hopefully when you die
according to plato's socrates you will
actually get to see the forums again
because that is one of the best things
available for human beings if if you in
fact hold this viewpoint
those sort of things follow
this was a very attractive viewpoint it
made its way into
a lot of different philosophies that
were not necessarily tied to plato
they made it into christian philosophy
and a lot of jewish philosophy and
muslim philosophy
this this notion that there are you know
these forms
these archetypes that what we're seeing
here is not
as real as what is say in the mind of
god plato doesn't talk about it that way
but this became a very influential idea
and this notion of the allegory of the
cave as being the story about
education
became very influential as well
this is one of those big ideas
that i would like you know
if i meet you on the street 20 years
from now and you've forgotten most of
the philosophy stuff that we studied in
this class that you can still tell me
about the allegory of the cave because
it's that important it's that culturally
important
um
you know you may not be able to tell me
anything about what thrasymachus said
but but this is
you know this is something to take home
something to keep with you
and it's got a lot of other applications
let's think about this now in a more
metaphorical sense
what other caves might there be
you notice for the picture
that i have in the the ilearn
section on this
i've got that you know i always put
those little pictures in there and often
they're like philosophy what did i have
uh
who's in the cave
a bunch of people right
is there anything do you guys remember
that image
anything unusual about those people
they all had two hands
two feet
remember what their heads were like
television sets
and they're all sitting around watching
a television
now of course plato didn't know anything
about television
he would have been kind of interested to
see it
think about the allegory of the cave and
cable tv
think about some of the features that
this has in common
are there people to sit around watching
tv all day long
do you know any
maybe they're not in class but they're
sitting back in the dorm right now
or you know they're your cousin or
somebody you went to high school with
doesn't necessarily have to be the tv it
could be you know constantly looking at
their iphone right
um
how do you know
that all those images that you're
you're you know
having stream in
are actually
representing anything real i mean it's
not a big deal if you automatically
assume they're not like if all you do is
watch cartoons
in a way watching cartoons all the time
would be better for you than watching
reality shows
reality shows yeah because because
reality shows purport to be
reality and that stuff is going to rub
off on you if you watch enough of it
the crassness and the crudeness and the
you know jerky behavior
you let you know you sit there and watch
that long enough you will eventually
come to say yeah okay i can i could see
how that could be reasonable maybe i
should act like that um and you don't
think you will
but you know we all succumb to that sort
of thing
you know that's that's a realm of
shadows
most of the stuff that you see on tv is
highly scripted
reality shows are a great example right
you guys have all seen these reality
shows how are they
scripted and produced
for entertainment well that's not the
first
real can you think of any of the ways
any of the techniques that they use
i mean first of all
do they do they just grab 10 people off
the street
if you are you know really well adjusted
you're not going to be on a reality show
you can get along with people really
well
you're not going to be on a reality show
why
not
yeah well because with all the fighting
stuff that's entertaining that's the
drama yeah i mean if everybody's sitting
around
i don't know should we have pizza
tonight yeah pizza sounds really good
what movie do you want to see i don't
know let's take a photo
we all like this movie right let's let's
do that that's pretty boring television
it's a lot more fun when you know
somebody
sort of knocks the table over and says i
had enough of your crap
you know
um
that's what actually
works now is that
is that really representing the way
human beings either
generally are
or ought to be
but but it's very entertaining to watch
um let's think about some other
things along these lines i've used this
example before
think about love songs
right
music can actually be a really good
um
medium for communicating truth
i in in one of my classes today
you guys all know that song cats in the
cradle
i used that
in a few weeks we're going to be looking
at aristotle's nick and mccain ethics
and i use that to illustrate something
about aristotle's nick mccain ethics
that's a song in which there's a very
painful
truth involved the character realizes
hope i really screwed up
and here's how i screwed up
that's not the way most songs go though
right think about love songs now
and
the way they depict the way couples
ought to interact
some of them are probably good
i love songs realistic
they sound really good i mean because
they're music
can you think of any that are good
examples of
something that might be
harmful over the top
totally unrepresentative of normal human
behavior
no
think about that though i mean all of
you listen to music right
and all of you
listen to
what are songs all about i mean there's
love songs
there's songs about we're going to party
you know you can change it up a whole
bunch of different ways
but it's basically the same song you
know
we're gonna stay up real late have a
good time
um could be you know we're gonna
i'm gonna rock and roll all night and
party every day i'll kiss it could be
you know um let's get this party started
or yeah pick anything you want so the
same song
it's the same sentiment
so you have love songs you have we're
going to party songs
you have
songs about something bad that happened
a lot you know
old irish songs are like that about the
english crushing
things along those lines
um
songs about missing somebody i guess
that's a love song isn't it though
usually
what i what other kind of songs do we
have
songs about how you're going to crush
somebody
you know destroy them
you know oftentimes they they combine
the party and the crush somebody songs
too you know that might that may be part
of the focus of the party for some of
the genres of music
but you know these are not depicting
reality to us really good songs actually
like open up reality and show us
what's beyond they challenge us
they're not just
easy for us to deal with
that's the way great artwork is great
movies
they challenge us
they try to make us grow and often it's
painful
can you think of any other cases in
a lot in our lives where
something like the allegory of the cave
takes place where somebody moves from a
position
where they and the people that they're
they're in with are
in illusion they're mistaken about
things they're not actually getting
what's really going on
and then they something that leads them
out of them
what are some other things that are like
that
i think all of you have probably
experienced one or two things like that
in your life
have you ever left a click behind
any of you
raise your hand
a group of people that you were in with
all of you stayed with exactly the same
people your entire
elementary school middle school high
school you didn't depend on them
i mean if you haven't you should that's
part of the growing process
maybe you miss them some of them
but
think about the way clicks work you know
they tend to be very closed in
cloistered almost
they require you to act a certain way to
think a certain way you have to stay
within certain limits they're actually
very very restrictive they're
very conservative even if they're like
all about
posing the man and you know telling you
know speaking truth to justice or any of
that sort of stuff they all do it the
same way within the same boundaries
how did you end up getting out of that
yeah you started
getting friendly with new people i guess
yeah i mean you could just go from one
click to another though that way
um
did any of you arrive at at the
conclusion that maybe there's more to
life than
hanging out with this group of
4 to 14 or 20 people
over and over again and saying the same
things and having the same thoughts
did anybody intervene in your life and
make a difference
and i'll you know pull you up and say
hey you know you're better than that
if so you had a cave
that somebody dragged you out of that is
probably very painful right at first
you didn't know how to behave at first
and then after a while things started to
get more clear to you
and you started to gain more perspective
and then after a long while you can you
can hardly see how you could have
been acting like that
at that time
there's a lot of cases like that
you know
very extreme cases would be like say
being in a game you know growing up
in a very tough neighborhood some of the
guys that i used to teach up at indiana
state prison were former gangster
disciples or vice lords
or some of them a few of them were latin
kings
those are the three big
umbrella gangs in the city of chicago
in the midwest
and um it was you know almost like a
whole world
you know if you wanted to
if you wanted to
go up in the ranks you had you had
binders full of documents that you had
to memorize
full of uh signs and rituals and you
know the history of the gang and all
this stuff i mean these were pretty
smart guys
you know they they were really good
students
um
how did they get out of that well you
know it took going to prison
for all of them
and then it took for a lot of them a
couple of years
of
getting thrown into solitary and getting
in fights with guys
and then
you know some some of them actually came
to their own conclusion on their own
they said hey this is bs i got i gotta
knock this off
most of them it was because somebody
cared about them
and came in and said
uh hey let me show you a different way
and then you know what happened
over and over again they said i don't
like this way i want to go back
and they insisted
they
kept dragging them along
and they didn't allow them to
to just you know give up and go back to
the realm of copies or shadows or the
facsimile of life not the real life
and then eventually they became
comfortable with it
and then some of them actually went back
and
pulled others out too
this is this is a a process that has
been going on
generation after generation for
millennia plato has just given you a
story by which to think about this the
way the
process actually works
i mean do you really have to commit
yourself to plato's doctrine of the
forms to for this story to make sense to
you
no how many of you are now platonists
and buy into the doctrine of the forms
you don't believe that there's a whole
world out there
where there's you know ultimate justice
and ultimate human you know humanity and
maybe ultimate cupness or you know
something like that
the perfect circle
no
no
it is a little implausible when we put
it like that i mean plato gives you some
other arguments for it i'm
kind of
joking around about it right
i'm
just downplaying it's
it's uh plausibility
but yeah none of you are are platonists
in this sense
you might think ideas are realities
i suspect you probably do because most
people do
and you might get lateness in that sense
and that's okay
you can do this without necessarily
tying in with the doctor in the forums
you can make sense of this story
does this sound like any
stories outside of philosophy outside of
social life does this sound like
stories that religious people tell
what do you think
i was a sinner
when i was saved
i didn't realize that god showed me the
real world and everything's perfect well
they don't always say necessarily
everything's perfect i mean they'll say
you know i'm still struggling or stuff
like that but they they very often
you'll see
people and it's all across different
religions saying
um i was you know stuck in this this
viewpoint where i couldn't see straight
and then you know god showed me the way
or you know
uh you know whatever you want to call
the divine showed me the way or i met a
holy person and they showed me the path
and stuff like that and
now i actually see things rightly
and then what do they do they often want
to go back on a mission
to give something back this this can
have a religious significance
this can have a social significance this
could have personal significance
it can do just with the process of
education
notice there's always the same elements
in it right there's initial reluctance
to abandon
where you're you're comfortable with
right
it takes a lot of struggle before
this actually works for you it's not
like the movies where in the matrix you
know you just put in some chips and
you're
now a kung fu master and stuff like that
if you want to you know if you want to
see realities you have to work at it and
you have to do a lot of
exercising your mind to
enable yourself to to do that and it
gets easier and easier the more that you
do it
and then there's the
return
and quite often disappointment
um
i'm going to tell you a story
that i told to another class that that i
talked about this was recently
and then we'll talk about aristotle
and we'll be done with plato for a while
um
when i was a graduate student i i got
into a depression
and
you know
you may you may go through something
kind of similar with your studies you're
all studying different things right
and
some of the things that you're studying
it's really easy to figure out why
you're studying i mean if you're
studying to be you know pre-med or any
of you pre-med well you don't know yet
oh you do know okay
you're getting you want to be doctors
right why do you want to be doctors you
know put aside the stuff like make a lot
of money or i want prestige you want to
heal people
it's pretty easy to figure out what your
purpose in life is isn't it
that might be what's attracting you to
it that you want to have a purpose in
life
are any of you planning on being
teachers
okay
you want to educate other people
right probably k through 12 you're
thinking okay
um are any of you in criminal justice
is one okay it's pretty easy to figure
out what you do with that
keep the bad guys locked up there's more
to it than that of course but that's
that's a big component
psychologists anyone who want to be a
psychologist
or a
what else do they have a lot of here
you know they have a fashion program
here that's pretty big
anyone in the fashion program
it's pretty easy to figure out what
you're going to do with that right
your life has purpose
now if all you're doing is reading
philosophy texts over and over again and
you read a lot of them and they say all
different things and you know they don't
agree with each other and you may wonder
to yourself
why in the hell am i doing this
i could be out doing all sorts of other
things and then now not just as an
undergraduate
but then you go to graduate school
and going to graduate school you're
going to be poor
and you're going to work
basically like a like you know slave
labor for
for the university that you're working
for i didn't actually have to do that
much of that because i got a fellowship
thankfully but i saw if you're a ta you
get a very small stipend and then you
get a cut in tuition and that's it
and you have to live on that
why do it what's the point you know why
spend the hour after hour after hour
learning what plato has to say
well so you can teach it to other people
right
well
what the hell's the point of that
what are they going to do with it
teach it to other people
is that where the real meaning of
studying these classic texts comes in
that you're going to pass it on to this
person and then hopefully they'll pass
it on to this person because most of
your students quite frankly
you know
you guys are actually you know very
attentive and you know i really
appreciate that
most of your students in most places
you're going to teach don't care
and you know you may reach one or two
students and they'll go on and become
philosophy professors and they're gonna
go teach plato too right
is that the point
and so you start thinking about this and
you think
oh my life has no meaning at all
you know i should just be out there
having a good time
this is this is crazy what i'm doing
so i told my uh my plato professor about
that
and i asked him what the point is was in
his teaching we were doing a plato class
he was teaching the symposium we were
reading it in greek
and he was an old man and he said
i look at it as i've
come to a fire that was around before i
was was there
and
other people tended that fire before me
and i don't owe them anything really
not anymore i've long since discharged
my obligations
but i like to warm myself by that fire
and i like to see by that fire and you
know if you want to come and sit by the
fire with me for a while too that's okay
and if you want to
sit here and tend it after i'm gone
that's good too
but you know what if you don't want to i
don't care
because i've got my fire
and it's good for me
because it's it's a good fire
and if it happens to go out after i'm
you know the last one to take care of it
it was still there it was good while it
went on it was worthwhile
that's the way these sort of stories are
that's the way the way philosophy is
getting outside of whatever cave that
you're stuck in is something worthwhile
and that's part of what you ought to be
doing
throughout the course of your education
so this isn't just about philosophy this
is about your your college education in
general
so that's awful preachy i know
but you know that's metaphysics and
ethics and where they come together
so
anything else anyone wants to say about
plato in the allegory of the cave or
we're leaving plato now
are you gonna miss them
no
maybe a little you know down the line
maybe if you spend enough time with it
later on right and that's actually my
goal for you guys
um it's not so much just to drill a
whole bunch of things in your head it's
to get at least some of you to continue
to read this stuff after the semester's
over to go back to it to be to be taken
by it to feel that there's questions
still unanswered for you
um that you feel you need to answer
so aristotle who who's this aristotle
guy i think all of you know from western
sieve what's his relationship to plato
was he his a son
b
best friend
c
bodyguard
wasn't those right
what was he somebody's about to say it
he was plato's student he was actually
plato's best student although plato had
a lot of students
aristotle supposedly studied with plato
for 20 years
and then plato
died or passed on to the world of the
forums you know
aristotle was very disappointed by now
plato had founded an actual school
called the academy we get the word
academy from that
aristotle did not get picked to be
plato's successor
he got passed over this just goes to
show you this sort of stuff happens all
the time those who are the most talented
don't always get the good positions
some guy who you know just happened to
be kind of a better platoonist than than
aristotle and was more liked by the
other people he got picked so what did
aristotle do um
in a way he was kind of an entrepreneur
if you don't like the company that
you're working at and you've got some
drive what do you do
make your own make your own right so
aristotle went off
and he very much departed from plato he
didn't buy into this form business
he thought there are forms
but they're not off in some other world
they're in the things themselves so
you want to see the form of human being
there's one right there
there's another one right there
there's another one right there
human being exists here and here and
here and here
where does desk exist
here
here
it's not in some other worldly place we
can see the form that connects all these
things together in the actual things
very different metaphysics
aristotle also has a very different
approach to
to writing
he didn't write
or at least he didn't leave us
dialogues the way plato did
aristotle is going to be
in some ways more straightforward than
plato that's probably good news for you
guys right
alas somebody who actually tells us what
he thinks
it's not quite so straightforward as
that though aristotle will tell you what
a whole bunch of people think
and then he will kind of sift it and
he'll say i think i think this is
probably right and this part's probably
right and this part nah i don't think so
and this has to be changed a little bit
and he's going to try to put them all
together in some sort of
grand
synthesis
that'll you know make better sense of
things so we're going to see this next
class you're going to read metaphysics
book one and that's going to be kind of
daunting
aristotle is going to be talking about
all these things that he calls
causes
the why
why things are the way they are
and ultimately he's going to talk about
four different kinds of causes and he's
going to talk about this person got this
part and this person got this part this
person got this part
that's because
he has a method that we call dialectical
with the dialectical method you begin
from
you don't begin from just nowhere you
don't begin by going off in a room by
yourself and imagining things you see
what other people who had something on
the ball had to say about whatever topic
you're researching
just like when you guys do research
papers right
you guys all remember doing research
papers in high school
you know you had to go and write a paper
on
farming or you know whether we should go
to war in iraq or who knows
was the teacher particularly interested
in you just telling you telling them
your your opinion right off the
bat if they were indulgent maybe they
were you know or if they were burnt out
um but but really what did they do they
said
i want you to go to the library
and to find out what some other people
said about this and then tell me what
they said and then you get to express
your own opinion
and you know you all did that right
and some of you when you expressed your
own opinion it was totally disconnected
from
the the sources that you looked at
and did that that work really well
you just reviewed a whole bunch of other
people and you said yeah now that i've
done this i'm going to tell you what i
think and it's not connected to any of
this
is that a good paper
probably
no of course not i mean why tell us
about these people if they don't have
anything to say that's that's
intelligent why did you pick those
sources were those the first books on
the shelf that you came across first
articles in jstor that's not how you do
research
you pick the ones that you think
actually have something worthwhile to
say
and then you criticize them
not meaning that you just tear them
apart you look to see where they're
right and where they're wrong that is
what aristotle is going to do
so aristotle is going to make sense out
of
all the people who came before him
he'll do this in metaphysics he'll do
this in ethics
he does this in other things that we're
not going to read uh in this semester
um but who knows maybe you will do on
your own he does this with poetics you
know artworks he does this with
rhetoric or communication if any of you
are planning on being con majors you'll
probably want to read some aristotle
this is again this is that dialectical
method you begin with
other people's views who you think might
actually have something to contribute
and then you examine them
look at them against each other and then
you go beyond them so you know with your
own papers what you if you wrote a
really good paper what you did
is you did precisely that you went to
the library and you found say five books
or five articles and you read through
them and you summarized them you didn't
even put you know one big block quote
that's 30 pages long right
you summarized it you boiled it down
that showed your instructor that you
actually knew something
didn't it
it demonstrated to them that you
understood a topic that you understood
what this person had to say
that's very important all of you by the
time you get here you have a lot of
skills whether you realize it or not
you're already on the way if you want to
be
to being good dialecticians like
aristotle
so what you did is you you summarized
each thing and you picked the sources
that you actually cared about and
thought might be intelligent and you
probably were tempted to you know
get rid of the ones that you disagreed
with right
but if you wrote a really good paper
you actually summarized the ones you
disagreed with too didn't you
and then you said your own view
and when you said your own view
you told your teacher
why you thought that this person was
partly right and partly wrong
and what this other person had to
contribute
all of you are sort of familiar with
this right you've all done papers like
that i think haven't you
now turn that around the other way
that's what aristotle's going to be
doing
so you know what he is up to
in a way
you don't know the topic that well
because you know you're being introduced
to the medicine sex
but you understand the way he's going
about it
yes
more or less
you feel a little bit more confident now
about
this is sort of a pep talk isn't it
you can do you can read aristotle and
you can't
every one of you if you put in the time
you are capable of understanding
enough of what aristotle has to say to
come to class and then
understand a bit more after the lecture
hopefully and then you know carry it
with you so
next class metaphysics some more and
we're going to be doing that for two
days
and then we move it back into ethics
again